mainstream media has characterized how
we see south asians
whether by romanticizing its biggest
country india
or asserting the model minority
stereotype
but it's not okay
and today south asian actors and
comedians are pushing back
[Music]
south asia is made up of several
countries located in the southern region
of the asian continent
as of 2015 4.9 million south asians were
living in the united states
hollywood often cast south asian roles
with white actors
and brownface look at the 1968 film the
party it's good to have a love
it stars peter sellers in brown faith as
roondy v
bakshi the film's ongoing joke is that
bumbling immigrants like bakshi
don't fit into the american lifestyle or
culture they're unintentionally invited
to
the party which they may very well ruin
[Music]
the 80s continue to show us more brown
face and the tolerated prejudices of the
time
but 1982's gandhi is a turning point
no more brownface here we have ben
kingsley of half
indian half english ancestry in the
starring role
gandhi's strategic civil disobedience is
a far cry from the way asians are often
depicted as a model minority that
doesn't rock the boat
it wins multiple oscars
[Applause]
then comes 1988 and the first season
of the simpsons hello steady customer
how are you this evening sir how are you
doing apple
two decades after the party peter
sellers accent inspires hank azaria to
voice one of the most popular
and most polarizing indians in
entertainment
how many uh had to deal with
like being called a poo or that being
referenced
a pooh becomes the most visible brown
face in american pop culture
but that doesn't mean more nuanced
stories aren't emerging
india-born director mira nair has
directed multiple films about indians
and the indian diaspora
her 1991 movie mississippi masala it's a
critique of where south asians often
place themselves in america's racial
hierarchy
i know you and your folks can come down
here from god knows where and be about
as black as the ace of spades and as
soon as you get here you start acting
white
and treating us like we your doormats
2002's bend it like beckham
is directed by gurinder chatta a kenyan
indian english woman
it's out of order anything i want is
just not indian enough room
these directors control over the
narrative gives us new ones complex
storytelling that's true to their
experiences
and while stereotypes do persist i am
taj
mahal films that push back against them
also gain popularity take 2004's harold
and kumar go to white castle
starring john cho and cal pen this film
plays officer in stereotypes of asian
americans
while challenging others you know my
whole life i've just been scared of
being one of those nerdy indian guys
turned doctor but tonight got me
thinking
i mean there are far worse things in
this world than being tapped for having
natural ability in medicine
south asians are no longer caricatures
like apu but we still normalize our
identities
under certain conventions whether
they're ambitious doctors
or the token ethnic person tasked with
being an expert on their culture
um diwali is awesome um
why don't you tell us a little bit about
the
origins of the holiday uh um
i don't know it's really old i think or
as sources of economic anxiety
we still want you to run the call center
in india
and then oh i meet man meat yes
your name is man mead needless to say
this show was cancelled after its first
season directors also play into viewers
fantasies about south asia
despite the region's diversity and rapid
changes certain narratives persist
around poverty enlightenment and
enchantment
india itself is a stereotype character
but we can't forget that 911 has
drastically changed the experience of
being brown in america
and so new stereotypes of south asians
emerge
did i beef oh no you didn't beat just a
random security check
random huh as terrorists
[Laughter]
and suspects throw your window down
huh the south asian comedians use humor
to point out the absurdity of these
tropes
so uh 911.
i've always wanted to have a
conversation with
about it you've never talked to people
about 911
no what'd you what'd you stand
anti it was a tragedy
i mean we lost 19 of our best guys huh
which brings us to today we see and hear
south asians finding their voices and
pushing back against cliches
we need you to do an accent you mean
like an indian accent yeah
uh you know i'd rather not i just feel
kind of weird doing that voice is that
okay
like other minority communities as south
asians gain more visibility in
mainstream society
their presence and representation in
movies and television
will continue to reflect that shift only
in america
can a first generation indian-american
muslim kid
get on this stage and make fun of the
president
[Music]
you